la chine a levé les restrictions
imposées depuis huit semaines dans la
province centrale de l'ubaye seule
exception la capitale régionale ou à un
berceau de la pandémie dans les rues de
nombreux avertissements rappelle que le
virus n'a pas disparu
la peur n'a pas dit non plus son dernier
mot et un retour à la normale est encore
loin dans la province où le dépistage
continue je suis resté à la maison
pendant deux mois et maintenant je peux
sortir et me détendre
mais même si les restrictions ont été
levées nous prenons toujours certaines
mesures et nous protéger bien qu il sera
certainement utile à tout le monde de
s'inspirer des expériences que la chine
a vécues avec le président chinois
défend cette coopération à
l'international si jean ping s'est
entretenu par téléphone ce vendredi avec
son homologue américain donald trump
pékin a promis d'agir et de travailler
avec la communauté internationale pour
vaincre la pandémie un message que le
dirigeant chinois avait déjà fait passer
ce jeudi lors de la réunion du g20
singh en faillite c'est un moment
crucial
un moment où nous devons relever le défi
et agir avec rapidité
je suis convaincu que grâce à la
solidarité à l'assistance mutuelle
nous vaincrons cette épidémie et nous
embrasseront tous un avenir meilleur
pour l'humanité
l'espoir renaît en chine mais le pays
prend ses précautions pour éviter que le
coc vite 19 ne revienne sur son sol
depuis l'étranger cette fois pékin à
fermer temporairement ses frontières et
réduit drastiquement les vols
internationaux
à partir de ce dimanche toutes les
compagnies locales ne pourront plus
effectuer qu'une seule liaison
hebdomadaire depuis la chine vers un
pays tiers une compagnie étrangère ne
pourra l maintenir qu'une seule desserte
par semaine à destination de l' empire
du milieu